firm Harvard and he's an expert in
causal inference and variant inference
as well as statistical machine learning
and he'll be talking to us about uh sort
of interference in networks yeah
all right cool
thank you so much
um thanks for the kind invitation I'm
really truly honored to be here uh this
is an excellent Workshop uh and very
topical as well so honor to to to be
part of it
um so this talk is about causal
inference in complex systems and it's
I'm going to present more like a review
of some prior work that I have done I
identify some of the issues and I'll
talk about my amazing collaborators
later
um okay so the standard methods of
causal inference
um whether the explicitly or implicitly
um stated uh they assume no interference
and no interference means that the uh
the outcome of the unit depends only on
the on the units uh treatment we cannot
be affected by other units at least this
has been the standard uh framework of
causal inference but of course this
assumes a simple in in study world and
as Vivek mentioned like describe many
real world settings they do have
interactions they do have uh situations
where units interact uh in in a dynamic
way and this type of problems aren't
just not solved there's a there's a lot
of Need for for new tools for methods to
address these problems and if you take
into account the modern problems in
policy making climate science uh
Healthcare modern Healthcare these are
all problems of causal inference in
complex systems so now more than ever uh
we need uh we need new tools and of
course the marketplace algorithms um
what what described Vivek
um earlier okay except for t-talk right
I don't like Tick Tock uh so
um anyway anything else and everything
else is important here so the main
thesis uh like of this talk like at the
summary is going to be that um I don't
think there's a one unique solution or
one unique approach in in complex
systems
um the solution depends on the context
and every context has a different let's
say characteristic and I don't think
there can be just one solution that that
fits everything however I do think that
the causal inference mindset the
framework can give us the foundation
like a unifying Foundation a common
Foundation to to address your problems
and I'll try to convey that as much as
possible in in today's stuff
some examples to illustrate the kind of
scope of problems that that are out
there of course by this is
non-exhaustive by by any
um uh any means
um but these are problems that I have
some familiarity with
um I have worked you know kind of in
also in uh with actual data
um and I will be able to describe some
of them in detail some of them only in
passing so this one is from a real
experiment uh in Medellin Colombia uh it
was a real experiment that uh kind of
randomized different levels of policing
on different street segments so what you
see here this map is Meridian downtown
uh the city of Medellin and here is a
street segment that's it the unit of our
analysis the red one is a street segment
that is in control it means it has the
Baseline policing and the blue here is a
street segment that received increased
policing and the question is is this
does this increase policing work do as
an intervention
but of course these these things are
they're not these three segments do not
exist individually right they are part
of the entire Street uh of the city uh
landscape and of course we expect that
street segments here are going to be
affected uh by nearby period streets or
nearby controls the streets for example
when you have more police presence here
uh you know criminals might move to that
that other control uh Street segment
okay that's it that's it that's
interference which means that the
outcomes that we see in that three
segment they depend on what happens uh
nearby okay it's not only what happens
on that three segment it depends on what
happened nearby now when we have
interference we suspect interference
it's even the definition of what we're
looking for the effects can be
complicated uh and so there I'm going to
describe some recent advances in in
really just describing kind of writing
down formally what uh what the estimate
is
um and and of course then how to twist
the middle another example is so-called
treatment habituation or treatment
learning uh this is especially
um important in cases where users kind
of learn uh like the units learn kind of
they look into the in treatment and they
start learning they adapt and so
um it's a special kind of interference
where in some sense even though there's
no there might not be interference
between units the unit interferes with
itself right so what I uh act how I act
today has kind of gives me some
information on how to to act tomorrow so
whatever treatment I received now has an
effect on what I'm going to do later so
it's a kind of an interference with with
a temporal interference also kind of
similar to what feedback talked about
earlier and this could mean serious
problem for causal inference and I would
say even econometrics and a high uh
profile public policy questions is
completely ignored in the sense that we
apply an intervention we measure
something and then we we kind of ignore
the fact that
um the effect that we see there might be
a strong effect now but down the road
the effect might completely like
drastically change right so the thing
about a very simple example you run a
grocery store you increase prices
overnight by uh 100 okay next day you're
going to see huge bum in your Revenue uh
choosing crazy you're Revenue perhaps
double uh a month later uh you might
kind of lose all your customers okay
that's uh kind of a because your
customers learn they kind of habituating
the treatment another example a very
famous one from Alton Rogers in 2014 and
they measure the effect of a mailing
campaign on household energy consumption
so basically they emailed households
they said okay here's how you yeah you
will not waste it but here how you
consumed in terms of energy here's how
your uh your neighborhood did and then
the households they did observe that
households immediately change their
energy consumption like drastically in
the first month but
um their initial conservation actions
were kind of halved after a couple of
months so the council habituated and
then they kind of received those those
males uh and then like this completely
ignored okay uh it's a big problem and
um there's just not a good solution out
there I'll just describe something that
we did with collaborators but it's still
an open problem
um another problem is you know you try
to introduce a new mechanism right in a
multi-agent system and you want to know
the the effects of that
um that's what perhaps Yahoo did uh in
2008 they're trying to increase their
Reserve prices because Theory told them
classical auction Theory told them that
they could increase the uh The the
Reserve prices in the auctions and it
will just get more revenue and not lose
customers okay that was a high profile
experiment that happened back then
that's an especially especially
challenging causal inference problem
because what you would like to measure
is your system being in auction one and
also your system being in option zero
um and the Baseline but you never get to
to observe it it's exactly the problem
that Vivek mentioned right you just only
get to observe some some kind of a mesh
or like a combination of these two and
as you can see here it didn't really go
it didn't really go that well Yahoo was
sold a few years later uh just a
graphical illustration of that problem
and again that's that's pretty much what
what Vivek talked about that was vivex
like half let's say uh mechanism that
you get perhaps you get to observe but
what you really want to know is what
will happen in your system if everybody
was assigned auction one what will
happen if you sign option zero and what
you really want to know is also the
long-term effect like the stationary
distribution of this tune so it's a very
um peculiar uh causal inference problem
because you just observe none of that
essentially you only observe get to
observe this data and you want to
extrapolate to these endpoints for which
you just have perhaps
um little information about it okay so
I'm not going to talk about that as
extremely uh hard as a problem
thankfully uh kind of vivec had some
some really cool results to show it's a
tough problem and it has a lot of uh
interesting uh future directions as well
so I'll focus more on example one
examples one and two well example one
was this crime spillovers where it's in
some sense it's the easy case there is
there something we can do about that uh
example two I'll just describe some this
example too I'll describe for
habituation I'll describe some
experimental designs that we um uh we we
worked on
okay so because causal inference means
different things to different people I
just would like first of all to Define
what type of causal inference I'm going
to talk about and then I'm going to
focus into two different types of causal
inference but the thing are uh perhaps
the the most uh promising one so at
least the ones that can offer that that
common Foundation that I promised
um so I'm going to use y for outcomes Z
for treatment X for covariance features
n is the number of units in my uh in my
sample I will be the index of that and I
want to understand the causal effect of
Z on y okay whatever Z is whatever Y is
for simplistic just assume that all of
these quantities are are scalars
um there are certainly four categories
types of causal inference one is a model
based approach right you can use a model
like a regression where you regress y
with Z on X still uh really popular I
would say the dominant approach and
sometimes it can be validated causally
with instrumental variables parallel
trans effective controls kind of
structural people impose some structural
assumptions on that still it is our
model based approaches
um another type of approach for causal
inference is is a so-called design-based
approach and surprisingly it's not as
well known as the model-based approach
and it's surprising because I will say
the design-based approach is more native
to causal influence like historically
causal inference at least in statistics
originated from experimental design
and experimental design is again design
is design means how I really assign the
treatment so design-based approaches
exploit the known variation in your
design that don't try to rely so much on
the model of the model of the watch
surprisingly though even though it's
more native to causal inference and also
historically
part of causal inference is not as well
known or as well
um
let's say um preferred as model based
approaches this has changed in recent
years especially through the works of
economists like uh like you know you
know evens who's uh who's a proponent of
design-based approaches
um still
um still they debate he kind of rages on
she will and the primary example is a
randomized studies right when you do
randomized studies
um you want to do what we call
randomization in France you want to do
your you want your inference to depend
on what how the experiment was was done
and I will say it Still Remains uh the
gold standard of causal inference I'm
sure it's a controversial statement
perhaps but
um I'm willing to talk about that over
over coffee later
um third disposal graphs big topic not
today uh forever
um and um and the other structural
models where I will say it's a model
based approach on steroids if you will
still very popular in macro policy
making uh what is that structural model
or DSG the dynamic stochastic General
equilibrium these are just big models
that try to predict how the system is
going to evolve think about the uh
um in the 2000s for example there was a
big debate on whether to introduce the
uh the the a common currency uh in
Europe right and they use these gigantic
models to uh try to fit like and then
compare what will happen to trade let's
say if you introduce the common currency
and how would that will compare to uh if
you didn't introduce that common
currency okay that and based on those
simulations or at least partially based
on those simulations they made the
decision to introduce the common
currents which is still very popular and
highly uh impactful I would say in
public policy but it kind of lives more
in the macro uh econ world not so much
in the uh in a micro
or in other other fields
okay so I'm going to focus on this
tension between model based and design
based and
um I'll spend some time
um let's say praising the merits of a
design-based approach which is going to
be my it's it's my personal favorite and
I'll try to to make the argument uh for
it so in trying to compare between the
model based approach and I want to do
that sorry I want to do that because
um some solutions that I'm going to
describe when it comes to interference
I'm going to employ a design based
approach so I would like to introduce
that first especially for those who
haven't seen that distinction before and
then kind of show some design-based
solutions for a causal inference when
there's a difference
okay what do I like
um the um uh design based approach so
much well the model based approach has
some really important pitfalls one of
course is that it requires correct
specification okay you need to have the
correct model in order to rely on a
Model based approach like a regression
or even machine learning which is uh
Which is popular nowadays if you don't
have the correct model you're open to a
lot of biases like think about this
decision to introduce the the common uh
the currency the entire Euro area right
like if you miss a factor like an
important factor in that big model your
conclusions your results might be why it
like widely misleading
um and they actually missed the factor
they missed the Greek Factor nobody
predicted that there will be that extra
coefficient about that you know Greece
will go bankrupt in a few in a few years
right so and it's hard to predict those
things right because there's so
heterogeneous so so such a complex
system
um another producers problem is but
relates to the workshop as well is the
quantification of our certainty uh
something that's not as as well known I
would say but it's a kind of a big
problem in practice and I could
introduce a math here but perhaps it
just a an example can illustrate can
illustrate that problem
suppose we have a completely randomized
experiment four units half of them are
in treatments here half of them are in
control
trade units have an outcome of eight uh
control units have an outcome of three
plus minus Epsilon
okay you run a regression Y and Z causal
effect is plus five okay
um it's an it's an experiment right so
economies actually would run a
regression like that because it's an
extra an experiment it was randomized it
has external validity good good what is
standard error from that regression
well if you look at that if you try to
visualize it you have some numbers three
here and there's some others that are
eight so for if you put them in a and Y
by Z axis okay so the data feed aligned
very well for an Epsilon that's zero so
the standard error that you get from
standard LS it's Epsilon
essentially
so the smaller Epsilon is in my outcomes
the larger my uncertainty
what happens here
is that the standard error estimation
the uncertainty quantification for this
modal approach model-based approach is
conflated with the model fits in other
words the closer the data looks like a
line the smaller the the smaller my
uncertainty is
and for me that's a that's a deal
breaker the fact that it conflates the
uncertainty with model fit that's a
that's a that's a that's a really uh big
problem
um so what can we do uh with that well
here's a design-based approach which as
I said it tries to to exploit the actual
variation in the experiments
um so the idea in design-based approach
is to try to predict outcomes that will
happen under kind of factual equipment
assignments and then try to compare with
what it was actually observed so in that
data for example suppose the kind of
factual was was flipped right suppose we
treated the units two and three but we
put the units one and four in control
kind of the the flipped version of what
it observed in data
actually this um experiment this
assignment has the same probability as
you know what we observed okay so it's
an equally likely uh kind of factual
so what will be the outcomes here this y
y Prime under this kind of factual
treatment assignment
um I don't really know right
a model-based approach we try to
predicted right but everything changes
on correct model specification so what
do you do well design based approaches
say okay let me try to make a hypothesis
about what's what's going on here
suppose for example that the treatment
has no effect on the outcomes suppose
that this Vector Z is independent of the
outcomes of Y
what will be the observed outcomes then
well I know that the observed arguments
will be exactly equal to what I observed
in the sample
right it's just a logical uh conclusion
so if the treatment has no effect on the
outcomes then this y Prime the kind of
factual outcomes will be exactly the
same so now I can impute those those
missing outcomes and I can redo my
calculation all over again run a
regression if you will or a machine
learning model anything
um now I can do this because I made a
hypothesis and I used the logical
conclusion of that hypothesis no
approximation so far and if you did that
the um the effect will be -5
not plus five okay will be the the exact
opposite now repeat that procedure for
all possible six randomizations here and
you'll find no significance uh because
this effect that we observe is plus five
although it's extreme it has a 17 chance
of happening so it's not at all
statistical significant and compare that
to the linear model that fit a line very
well and said oh that there's this data
I'm sure this data are aligned so uh the
kind of the center error was
artificially very very low okay and
again because it conflated the model fit
with our certainty quantification
whereas a design based approach does not
do that
why because introduces Noah something
this is just in some sense it's pure
logic right if again if you make a
hypothesis you kind of test the
implications of that hypothesis
okay so is that a general idea it is and
um it's called the features
randomization test and
um I think this idea is is should be in
these types of methods should be more
well known especially for those who run
experiments because they have some
really appealing properties that I just
briefly discussed uh soon so how do you
generalize this well suppose you have a
design uh it's a probability
distribution of recruitment can be as
complex as you want right it could be a
cluster design saturation design doing
something like really complex
this will y i zero y i1 the potential
outcomes under control and under
treatment per unit
and suppose we want to test the
hypothesis that the treatment has no
effect it's essentially your potential
outcomes are exactly the same regardless
of what treatments you received
so what is a feature randomization test
it's generalization of that idea I
described later
step one choose a test statistic and
that can be OLS it can be machine
learning any anything from simple to
complex
um doesn't really matter method is valid
regardless of the choice of a
pessimistic you build their
randomization distribution basically you
just resample your treatment according
to your design and you recalculate your
your statistic and then you compare What
You observe with what you that with what
you created like the organization
foreign why do I praise this method so
much because this method is valid in in
finite samples it's exact as we say
that's number one
um there's no asymptotics here I'm not
saying this in the limit this is for any
finite end so it works well for a small
sample it works well with a large sample
that's why it's it's preferred when you
have an experiment it's actually
preferred especially when you do a
medical trial people will not even
consider applying a model that just do
things like that because it just does
not rely on asymptotics
um we don't need a correct y model
specification okay and the test is
robust in the sense that transform wise
in kind of way in different Perhaps
Perhaps there's a different scale of
measurement right perhaps the data were
were measured in terms in the log scale
usually the uh the answer is the same in
most cases the answer that you get is
the same run regression in the log scale
instead of the normal the natural scale
the results can change completely
machine learning is also open to that
like you change the scale the the out
the uh the results can can vary widely
um so the um this randomization tests
have that property of robustness so all
in all if we talk about uncertainty
quantification which is you know the the
topic of this work so this method is
really when of course is possible to to
apply is really I will say the gold
standard in uncertainty quantification
because it's exact it does not require
any assumption whatsoever neither the
model nor the asymptotics
um of course there's no free lunch right
there are some disadvantages uh one is
that it tests strong hypothesis so what
I what I have over here is testing that
the treatment has no effect whatsoever
but what if it had heterogeneous effect
right what if we want to test the
average written effect like in on like
in the average of the population not for
every every unit as you see here
actually there's a lot of research
activity in that area and a lot of
recent evidence kind of points to the
direction that even in those cases the
randomization approach can give you some
robustness like it inherits the
robustness of the original uh the
classical organization method this big
area I'm not going to get into that the
other is coming mostly from the
economics world again economists will
say well I don't really care about the
sample right whatever you're doing is in
the sample I want to know what will
happen in the entire us right or in the
entire States or the entire world this
is too too restrictive for me
um and that's true that's a fair it's a
fair criticism to me that's more like
more like a feature it's not a bug
um in the sense that you have to
understand when your inference you have
to understand the limits of your
inference right is the inference applies
in your sample or or in other words what
is a boundary after which you start
speculating
okay and I'll I'll talk a little bit
about that later when I talk about the
uh The Meta giving example okay so all
you know I should I will say the
following when it's possible to apply
and I cannot apply in in all settings
but when it's possible to apply I really
think that this design-based approaches
especially this feature randomization
test their organization test methods
should be in the toolkits of every
experimenter of every analyst because
one when it's possible to do they give
you this exact accelerative
quantification much better than a model
based approaches
okay so if hopefully I have convinced
you about the merits of that design
based approach so I would like to going
forward try to see how this method
change when interference comes into the
mix because so far I have made that
assumption that I can really write uh
why I zero y A1 right the control
potential outcome and the treatment uh
potential outcome
now even when you write this notation
down and there are people who don't
really like uh that notation even they
kind of consider it to speculative uh
Jersey name and it was was one uh Peter
McCullough is another
um anyway kind of barring those kind of
more foundational let's say uh debates
um when you write down even that that
notation you you kind of assume away
interference right uh you kind of assume
assume a way that my art the outcome for
unit y for unit I could depend on the
outcomes of neighboring neighboring
units like remember that made a Yin
example okay so in one of those
treatment interference uh spillovers
Dynamics contagion you cannot even write
that down
um you need some different different
notation right you need some different
definitions
um so when there's interference the unit
is exposed to something more than
individual treatments
it's some kind of a net effect from the
population that the markets the city
well it's it's uh like a thing of
vaccine trial right a control unit is
still protected by uh an unvaccinated
person is still protected by a
vaccinated person that's another example
from the fruits and I described describe
some examples earlier so what do we do
how do we write down even these outcomes
like what how can we handle this type of
complexity
well some kind of consensus I think that
has emerged at least in the stats
literature uh has to do with the this
concept of of treatment treatment
exposure
um and treatment exposure I'm going to
use F5 of Z this Z is the entire
population the entire Children of the
population and this f i z think of it as
the summary uh the net effect of the
exposure that flows from the population
into one unit
and so the the kind of leaders or the
consensus or the literacy is converts to
considering that interference as
mediated in some some way as being
summarized by a function okay so this is
the entire population
um share some examples like in the
standard setting where there's no
interference that exposure is really
only your individual treatment okay
that's the standard setting but Suppose
there are households and then um your
exposure could be your own treatment
plus the treatments of
um people in the in the household that's
a cluster design where a household is a
cluster or could be the treatments of
nearby cities if you have let's say a
randomization on the cedar level or it
could be something that's uh
multi-valued right it could be your own
treatments and the treatment in the
household so you can have an arbitrary
definition
in in general this fiz is the exposure
has is is comprised by your own
treatment and some summary perhaps some
numerical summary hopefully of what
happens in the population of the
treatment population okay now although
it's not necessary it's useful to think
that you know one hit this exposure this
perhaps High dimensional multi
multi-dimensional object is is equal
across two different assignments your
outcomes are going to be equal as well
so if we fix that exposure
um across different assignments your
outcomes are going to be fixed it's not
an exclusion restriction effective
treatment in Mass these words it's it's
um it's an idea that has been around in
in general like in statistics and
economics it's not an entirely new
okay how is that useful though
um in in doing causal inference under
interference well one might say I can
just take that and just run a regression
again right uh well
approach now that we have all the
problems that I described earlier and
some more so when you introduce exposure
like that and people do that actually
like they will write regressions where
this could be let's say the average
treatments of your neighbors and running
regression like that now there are some
additional problems uh to what in
addition to this model based problems
some additional problems are you don't
you don't really know the correlation
structure between these two things right
this can be a really complex objects and
also doing asymptotics based on that it
is also uh entirely even intractable in
most in most cases you have to impose
some assumptions perhaps on network you
need Network asymptotics in many cases
so it can be really messy so and yeah
certain quantification if it was
problematic before it's going to be
problematic uh even more problematic
here
sometimes even people put the outcomes
not the treatments also the outcomes of
your neighbors here what they call
linear means Etc that's a No-No uh and
Josh angris has an excellent article
about the Perils of pure effects and the
kind of progressions that people run uh
that's never never never a good idea
because basically you just don't really
know what this is estimating uh we're in
a territory where things are not even
identified so um okay so if we if I
convince you that the model based
approach the problematic what can we do
can we apply the design-based approach
that described earlier
in many cases we can and in cases where
we want to to test whether the outcomes
are equal for diff for two different
types of exposures let's say okay this
null hypothesis we can call them perhaps
contrast hypothesis uh they have
appeared in the literature in many uh
different uh forms
um and I'm going to talk about one of
that in the in American example just
before I describe that I should say the
following that
um if we're going to test
um that if if this if it's equivalence
null hypothesis we're going we want to
test is a subset of all the possible
exposures then we kind of run into
problems this is what we call a weakness
hypothesis but if we were testing that
if this F naught here was equal to the
entire set of possible exposures then we
will be back to this original frt right
which is kind of run the classical
Liberty it will be completely fine so
the literature the recent leadership has
focused on testing this uh kind of weak
null hypothesis
so let me give you an example and
hopefully will be more clear
so suppose go back to this meta again I
want to know whether there are spillover
effects from nearby treated streets on
control Street okay how do I even write
this down well one way you can do this
that's kind of the approach we we took
was to say okay let's focus on two kinds
of exposures I'm going to call them
control speed lovers and pure controls
what's a pure control pure control is an
ex a type of exposure where the unit is
through segment is in control and
there's no treated Street nearby
okay I don't think oh perhaps this one
here this one here could be a pure
control straight right because there's
no neighboring uh treated uh Street on
the other hand there are the there's the
exposure that we call control spillovers
that is again a control strip
but there's a nearby treated Street
so that could be a controls below versus
exposure controls below versus exposure
control spillover exposure and that will
be a pure control
I would like to know whether that
there's any difference between those
kinds of streets and those kinds of
three streets in terms of crime outcomes
let's say okay so what I did so far is
to define a language to describe
spillover effects through that idea of
treatment exposure and as you can see
here this definition depends on my own
treatment and the treatment that happens
near me
of course these definitions can change
um but let's let's let's all agree that
these are some reasonable definitions
for trading Exchange
okay now one thing here that that you
have to uh notice is that these are not
these are not exhausted right it's not
only that control they're they're only
not only just these two types of
spillovers
um you could be a tweeted straight and
still have a spillover from a straight
edge strip okay
so there are more types of treatment
exposures that we could have uh
introduced but suppose that you are a
criminologist and you're interested only
in these two types of effects
how will you test that well if you try
to use that feature in this area and
randomization test that I described
earlier you're going to have some
problems so what is the problem uh
here's just one example
um suppose this was the actual
experiments and suppose remember what we
did in the in the example before we just
shuffled the treatment Vector right
suppose we do that and in this shuffling
this unit here from from Red it became
blue
okay now I need again to think about
what will be the kind of factual outcome
what will be the outcome of that
straight under this kind of factual
treatment assignments
well the realization here is that my
null hypothesis is not strong enough to
tell me what that outcome is because
remember the null hypothesis only says
that the outcomes under control speed
lovers are the same as pure control
that's it it doesn't really and both of
these exposures require you to be in
control they tell me nothing about what
happens when you are treated once this
zi is equal to one that's why we call it
a weak no hypothesis it doesn't really
give me all the information that I that
I needed okay so what do we do we cannot
apply this classical design method
um
just as easily so the main Insight of
recent literature is that you have to
condition on a subset of your data
essentially you have to use a subset of
the units and subset of the assignments
and then perhaps do the randomization
test in that subset essentially throw
away some of your data
so that that that that
um you have to throw away some part of
the data that it just cannot be
um
for which the the null hypothesis is no
cannot give you any information
essentially
uh how can you do this conditioning like
how what subset of of your data to to
focus on uh well actually in this type
of performance there is a nice trick
that you can do that produces a problem
from a statistical one to a
computational one and it goes like this
so you put the the units of your
analysis in our case it's the switch
segments on one side we take all the
possible uh treatment assignments on the
other side so here uh just a
clarification this this bullet here is
not uh this is not it's not an
individual treatment this corresponds to
population treatment like an entire
thing of this as an entire Vector for
the entire population
so you put this on one side the units
and then this population pretty
assignments on the other side
and you connect the units and an
assignment with an edge
if this unit under that assignment is
exposed to the exposures defined in the
null hypothesis then we just draw an
edge and you do that for all possible
combinations we call this the null
exposure graph and so far again I'm not
making any assumption about the model
any assumption about this is really the
the The Logical structure of your
statistical problem encoded in a graph
essentially okay and by looking at it it
gives you a lot of valuable information
for example the more dense this graph is
it means that the more units are exposed
to the exposure signal hypothesis the
more information you have to test your
scientific uh hypothesis if this was
empty it would be impossible to answer
your null hypothesis so in some sense
it's also it gives you information it
illustrates makes it transparent how
much information you have for your
scientific problem of Interest something
that's really hidden uh obfuscated by
model based approach because a model
based approach is going to to grab your
data and kind of give you an answer okay
but in the process it might be doing
circulations that you don't want to be
making how are given a concrete example
layer
um and so and next year another
important
um uh observation here is that the nedge
is also equivalent to impurability which
means the following that essentially if
you want to run the feature optimization
test for these types of null hypothesis
you're looking for a by click in that
graph representation
essentially your statistical problem
becomes a computational one you find a
by clicking that in that graph and then
you run uh that again you just run the
classical method as as usual okay why
you buy click because a by click means
that all the units are connected to all
the assignments in that bytext and why
is this important because in a by click
this means that you can make those
imputations uh these imputations are
possible across assignments this Z Prime
and Y Prime these are possible only in a
bike lane so it's an if and only if
actually
um and so here's how you you change that
classical frt you calculate Danny graph
you take that click this by click that
contains the treatment The observed
treatment assignment and you run your
feature test in your randomization test
in that by click so yeah essentially
this is a trick it's an algorithm to
automate how how to subset the data in
order to test your hypothesis and run
this design-based approach that uh you
know has this nice appealing problem
okay other than that is the classical
the classical map
and so it inherits all the nice
properties of robustness
Etc of the organization tests here's how
this looks like in the Medellin example
this is the city of Meridian and every
dot here is a street segment the blue
ones are treated units the light blue
are
um control spillovers these are these
are streets here this light blue are
streets that were assigned to the
Baseline policing but they have nearby
streets that have had intensive policing
um and the uh this navy blue here are
pure control units these are units that
are in control and they don't have
treated streets nearby
this red one are the focal units as we
say the literature has conversed into to
that to that to that terminology focal
units means that this is a subset of
your data that will give you that will
help you test your node hypothesis
essentially we're going to run our
randomization test only in this green uh
dots essentially which are some of them
are in the outskirts and some of them
are in the center
okay why is this picture is so important
because it tells you it tells you that
the structure the the subset of the data
that's relevant to your scientific
hypothesis your scientific hypothesis
has a very complex structure
and if you try to run an aggression
immediately on all your data essentially
you're going to be using those the
non-green dots and when you use the
non-grade dots you're extrapolated
necessarily no doubt about
you're going to use the model to
extrapolate to those units whereas
randomization tests in some sense is
honest honestly tells you look look man
this is this is the only thing that I
can do here these are the only units
that are exposed or could be exposed to
the exposure that you want to the
interference effects you're interested
in yes yes
right to sort of make some interest uh
on you know whether I'm violating or not
or not
looks like if I'm pulling things across
them I have to make further assumptions
on aspect right because otherwise how do
I look right let's imagine I had uh you
know one two three four and I have a
bike lick for one two a bike lick for
three four right so you
you can speak to uh rejection uh in
either of those groups but ideally you
want to talk about rejection across the
whole thing and I don't understand how
you talk about projection collectively
that's an excellent point well the the
actual method that we propose is I kind
of Hit the details
um you build this growth then we do this
decomposition as you mentioned
essentially I take this graph in a
decompose it into different white clicks
but then only one by click contains the
observed uh Treatment Center there's
only one subset so I don't have to pull
around yes
um and you have to do that because of
the Liberty reasons uh it's it's more
effective it's an excellent
question are we also Define
foreign
and that's the criticism of uh your your
um your formulation being too
restrictive right yeah and uh I I fully
accept that uh but in in a sense you
know if you want to really this is this
is the inherent trade of the trade of
all that method it tells you I can test
something really exactly uh no no census
no synthetics but it has to be something
restricted I cannot say anything about
other turbine exposures or other units
of underestimate or other estimator
yeah it is what it is
um okay so but again I want to emphasize
the complex instruction
method will never figure out that these
are the units that are relevant to my
specific null hypothesis and it will and
do extrapolations that perhaps we didn't
intend to
um here's a spin-off of these ideas is
first of all we could use that method to
uh warn the user when you try to do this
type of extrapolation
um and there was a paper about the
effects of large-scale social media
advertising in with copy defections that
was by Brazil at nature so essentially
they had a an advertising campaign uh
over across States in order to vaccinate
et cetera Etc and if they wanted to
estimate a part of that was to estimate
pure effects uh spillover effects
between states of this advertising
campaigns and the user aggression-based
approach okay fine I don't want to be a
negative two very negative person
um however you could use that method to
figure out the size of the sizes of
these bike Lakes right so and this is
the plot using their data that kind of
gives you the trade-off let's say that
that um of of your problem so
essentially every point so this point
here this this curve here corresponds to
different combinations of assignments
and units these are by click essentially
the the size of the bike League where
they tell you how many units you can use
to test your your particular null
hypothesis uh and so
um this tells you that for example
um in in in their particular case in
this particular Point here uh you could
have a situation where you have 10 focal
units and only 10 assignments it's a
really small
um bike very small bike like size which
tells you that you might be
extrapolating too much I'm not saying
that the paper is actually struggling
too much but it's more like a diagnostic
right you definitely would prefer to be
um you definitely prefer curves that are
kind of higher right uh the more units
you have the more assignments you have
in this test the better is that the more
kind of honest information we'll see uh
is that you're using another spin-off is
um for improving experimental design so
even before anything starts even before
you observe outcomes but remember this
this graph that I described is really a
reflection of the problem structure I
haven't we haven't assumed anything
about the model itself it's really the
you know kind of encodes how difficult
your your problem is so you could try to
have a parameter space for your your
experimental design and try to find that
experimental design that gives you the
the bigger bike essentially okay and so
bigger bike clicks hopefully will mean
more powerful methods and here is an
example where
I show you here on the right this this
kind of shows you uh on these two axes
we have the parameter space so P0 in the
metagen example P0 will be the
probability of treating a straight in
the outskirts and P1 will be the
probability of trading straight in the
center suppose it's very simple design
space and you can kind of plot that and
show that where do I get the largest by
clicks okay kind of this is this this is
the more shaded area and using a
simulated model for the outcomes you can
see that there's a correlation between
the power I compute from a simulated y
model to what I compute from the uh this
by click kind of a algorithm this tells
you this kind of picture tells you that
you could use this bike lady
compositions in order to optimize an
experimental design essentially and you
could prefer experimental designs that
lead to bigger bike steps
okay uh I don't think I have too much uh
time
one minute okay so I was planning to
talk about this habituation effects uh
which are pretty
um as I said it's a big problem in in uh
in uh kind of on online Commerce
especially it was a nice paper I want to
call it out from from Google where they
wanted to estimate this I I blindness
right that affected what people get get
a treatment but then they kind of start
habituating uh on it
um and
they have some interesting examples they
kind of have different experimental
designs This was
um now your treatment is temporal it's
kind of over time uh this will be the
where you get the treatment across
different uh of course all time periods
Etc
um and what I want you only to to to say
here is perhaps that
um we kind of analyze experiments like
that and we kind of um worked on on
finding Minimax experimental designs uh
and kind of uh the the main finding
there was that the Minimax design and
when you want to estimate this type of
habituation effects that we focused on
is still a completely randomized design
but imbalanced depending on imbalance
across these different types of
assignments
um so I know it's it's still still too
brief it's too I'm going too fast but uh
just just give you an idea that we
worked on kind of Minimax experimental
design in that area as well which is a
special title movement
okay so let me wrap up uh just to
hopefully give you some taste of what
causal inference is in complex systems
uh and and again I will to repeat that
it's incomplete because this type of
causal inference is is underdeveloped
um standard practice so far kind of
assumes the way this interference and
complex uh treatment Dynamics
habituation and things like that
um now what I present here is only just
a tiny sample of what what's possible I
didn't talk about strategic behaviors
Marketplace Dynamics many different
things that that you could do
um and uh we just were able to work on
these issues like the policing
experiment in metagin or the uh this
habituation effects from and designs
with habituation effects
um and with that I can give a shout out
to my excellent collaborators is not
here he used to be a sampled
um Ali Feller he's uh he's he's close
um uh pong ding who's um at Berkeley
stats as well David Parks was a Harvard
equals yes and yeah that's it thanks for
your attention
[Applause]
I will take questions offline uh let's
thank both Panos and Vivek again
[Applause]
we'll be back at 11 15.